question I had is you
extensively on nationalism and on
nationalism in in Croatia and it seems
like you know the times have caught up
with you in a way one of the one of the
themes in your in your work is how how
things don't change
so in Croatia and Bosnia and Serbia
these countries you know things things
change the 90s and ever since then we're
stuck in in a kind of kind of time
unchanged because because they can't
change because nationalism itself is the
project which is so you know which is
like a prism there is no way out yeah
ideologically it is so stupid and so
empty and so simple and so obsessive
that there is nothing behind us you know
communism was far more open project
because you could change it you could
you could discuss it you could do this
or that
I'm in each of communist countries there
they had their own in spite of the same
ideology but they had their own
communist story but nationalism is
something like tooth pain you know
you're just whining and whining and
whining and this is Italy thinking yeah
but you you know you speak from from
your own experience and and and from
from Croatia but it seems like you know
that the rest of the world used to think
that nationalism was gone was a problem
of the past almost and now we're faced
with this situation blooming it is now
it is yeah I think that my belief in to
humanity and to human creature is such
strong that I'm always a sucker so so
again with with Trump I was 100% sure
that he won't win because especially
because III was watching those Alex
Baldwin apparently so I simply could not
believe but I was I was wrong I should
simply think about the knowledge I
and and and remember that knowledge why
it is why nationalism why populism it is
so sweet why it is so sweet when you
were Slavia fell apart and when
nationalists sworn on all the side there
was a such a I could feel that a relief
among people because now I know that
communism was demanding system with all
that ideology you know that you have to
go to school you have to educate
yourself
I mean free education girls to the
school I mean it was it was yes it was
liberating yes it was emancipatory
because I mean you could succeed succeed
only because if you were smart you were
educated and dedicated dedicated
knowledge was like a god it was the holy
thing okay I'm saying you're saying a
socialism was a pain you shouldn't miss
a kind of religion it was it was
demanding and then self-management God
people have to I mean learn that
self-management they have to you know
they had tools democratic tools how to
how to manage their factories their
firms their whatever so all of that was
demanding when nationalism came you had
to love Serbs and Slovenes and
Macedonians you have to learn all those
languages you have to travel this and
that always demanding suddenly
nationalism came and you were respected
for one thing only being right blood
time those possibilities which you can
get with nationalism it is all it's not
about only about
attraction it's about power it's about
possibility of money it's about a huge
possibility of change I will tell you
story nobody believes me but the story
is truth my publisher our boosters are
it's in Zagreb he was a main editor he
became thanks to Hadassah and his
participation in political he became a
chef of police creation police so
probably I mean visa you can't beat that
anywhere in the world except in those
special situations constellation you get
people who became something somebody
only thanks to this this constellation
where people were awarded for loyalty
people became millionaires just for a
little moment of loyalty towards nation
huge money the people in power and so on
and so forth
this is attractive we live in
unbelievably dangerous times I mean
there is no arbitrage we don't want
arbitrage who is going to tell me what
movie I am going to lock okay at the end
we don't count in fact we all like one
movie okay Sam Shia met our last
conference made the same analysis he
said what what you basically went wrong
is that the values of the Enlightenment
were killed by amusements by commercial
culture right yes well but this is what
we call democracy people are free you
know to choose what they want and they
have a strong preference of you know
commercial culture amusement about what
fellas you have real life but so you
know and this is this is democracy this
is no communism this is
you know a small group who is imposing
XYZ yeah and so you know let's be happy
with it because we still live in the new
pope [ __ ] yeah I think we should be
happy so then I don't have anything okay
how them to relate to your statement you
know that we live in dangerous times
dangerous times yes dangerous times
because of illiteracy you go you think
that you you are choosing in fact you do
not choose you are chosen this is what
what what is for me such a discovery
when people it was never like that that
people would a dream it was never like
that before and that appeared with this
new time of consensus it was never that
people would agree that one writer let's
say goes globally and this is the best
genius that we can get everybody agrees
writers fellow writers critics good
critics audience which didn't read any
book but that one and so on and so forth
you know these are those who who is
choosing that why suddenly everybody
agrees that Elena Ferrante is genius I'm
not going to to put a footnote but say
now I think to that she's great because
I don't want to do that for the sake of
of this why is that so ten years ago did
it could not happen yes there were
bestsellers but it was not such a total
agreement in between formally hi writers
or thinkers or whatever and and and lo
or some literary and so on what about
the current situation in Croatia because
you described that
when you were young you were definitely
aware of what was good and what was evil
and then with this purification of the
library of the books of the history and
with this change of the perspectives how
it's a current situation right now how
kids are
oh they're aware of the situation of the
past history and how do they look
alright I was observing through 25 years
how those ideas a concept a system how
they penetrated into all the levels of
of life they penetrated into school
books into kindergartens into school
books into high school books into
universities they penetrated into
hospitals into media the radio
newspapers into people the the biggest
promoter of nationalism in creation was
khattala church from hardly maybe 5%
just old ladies before they went to
church increase according to to some
statistics there is a 87 percent of
declared Catholic Catholics so churches
everywhere and church is promoting and
implanting realizing all those all those
ideas
you